hey everybody and welcome to an
aggressive wild ride with steo one would
say it is aggressive to come out and
call Aaron roders and Cat Williams
losers but let me submit we're not
actually saying they're losers it turns
out only one of them is a loser so we'll
get into that but we've got a pretty
major special guest on the podcast it is
the very woman who skinny Vinnie is
going to marry this weekend and we asked
her if she thinks Aaron roders is
attractive and that is probably the only
not controversial question that we asked
her it gets crazy and also the bucket
list winner I I put it out there on my
socials that uh I want to fulfill
somebody's bucket list wish and this one
guy is dying of cancer he wanted to be
on the Wild Ride podcast and he had a a
special mission that he's on and and we
helped him to further that goal and
that's a touching and meaningful last
chapter to this very aggressive wild
ride with steo so strap on your seat
bels ladies and Gentlemen let's get to
it ladies and Gentlemen people of the
Universe I bring to you me and Scott
Rand and skinny Vinnie what's going on
guys well we've got a a special guest in
the van we sure do it's Vinnie's
fiance Autumn hi and this is important
because Vinnie is getting married this
weekend this Monday this coming Monday
and are you nervous I'm not are you
nervous Autumn I'm a little bit um
mainly for the ceremony I unlike him I
don't like being the center of retention
I don't like people just staring at me
um but I'm excited for like the
reception and everything and all right
what about spending the rest of your
life with
this we will get to that but Autumn are
you aware of the Aaron roders versus
Jimmy Kimmel situation I've been hearing
about it but I don't know that much but
I've seen it everywhere okay well to to
distill it down to its it's little in a
nutshell Aaron roders
insinuated that Jimmy Kimmel is on
Jeffrey Epstein's list and as such is
some kind of a predator of
children and um Jimmy Kimmel was none
too pleased about that fired off on
Aaron roders like devoted his entire
opening monologue on the Kimmel show to
just destroying Aaron Rogers and Aaron
roders since is no longer welcome on the
pat mcae show well only a certain not
the whole list came out right it was
just list came out but but uh Aaron
Rogers responded and he's like let me
clarify what I me yeah Aaron Rogers
responded basically saying let me not
apologize whatsoever and like try to
like get some digs in and like I mean
it's just a big catastrophic l from the
way I see it so our question at the
moment is who took the bigger L who's
the bigger loser of the week Aaron
Rodgers or Cat Williams but why would
you even think that Cat Williams took an
L well I mean this is the what did he do
what did he do that you didn't like I
mean hey he didn't do anything I didn't
like I'm just seeing that he attacked
everybody Under the Sun it seems like he
set about trying to burn burn every
bridge he possibly could I mean dude I
just went through a list but he said
he's like I have the receipts and
everybody he has the receipts for saying
that Harvey Weinstein offered to S his s
HISD in front of a bunch of people like
he said a lot of things that actually
there are no receipts for well nobody
has refuted anything that he had to
say so like people did respond to to to
cat but they never denied what he was
saying uh Tiffany hartish uh
categorically
denied uh she she refuted everything
that he said about her well didn't he
say that like the the the people that
are involved with the Inner Circle their
only job is to refute everything that is
claimed against them towards like the
Illuminati you didn't hear him say that
okay so now we've got receipts for the
Illuminati huh well I mean that's what
he's saying you know but nobody has said
anything
different I mean here's the thing um I
think that he uh slung a lot of mud he
he TR to burn a lot of bridges and um he
definitely got a lot of news I mean we
like the the most uh compelling thing we
could think of to start the podcast is
the story about him like uh you know so
you'd think that it was a huge W but why
think he goes on this huge platform and
just starts and just starts bashing
everybody do you think there's a little
bitterness between like everybody lit a
lot of bitterness for sure yeah yeah for
sure 100% there's bitterness with h
Kevin Hart and Tiffany hadish I forget
what the origin of that was but uh now
as far as career goes do you think
Tiffany hadish is more successful than
Cat Williams that's I don't know man Cat
Williams here's the thing dude Tiffany
haish went from like not a a like Big C
celebrity to a Bonafide like A-list
movie star and then she got tangled up
in in some kind of accusations and like
some kind of a lawsuit situation with
who Aries Spears was it and uh that
really really hurt her and then since
had
buchis really not a bunch she got two
but but still like when you get a second
DUI like it's so I think that I I love
Tiffany
I love her but I think that like
objectively like from a career
standpoint she like you know was she had
a quicker come up well no she she's been
doing standup since she was like a
teenager yeah and then she came up like
you know whatever like a few years ago
it's like uh more than a few years ago
but um but yeah she she came up a little
like after many many years of doing
standup came up humongously yeah
meteoric F straight to the boom like
like you know well so what do you
think's going to happen to cat after
this I mean he's going to be doing
larger shows because his popularity grew
and Rogan just invited him to go on
right I mean I mean he's he just blew
himself up and this is a new podcast and
I think it got like 2 million views 2
million subscribers overnight oh my god
dude that episode 41 million views in
seven days
how much money is that on AdSense okay
so that's literally just the the Cat
Williams episode has 41 million views in
seven days Jesus wow what's what's the
AdSense revenue on that at like $5 per
thousand if he's got mid rolls built in
uh I
mean every million views he's getting
$5,000 I think it's probably more like
every million views you get a ,000 oh
that's a dollar Still Still Still that's
uh that's 40,000 but if he's got mid
rolls then he's in the six
figures I I read something this morning
that he he got a quarter of a million
dollars just off of AdSense for this I
wouldn't be surprised I wouldn't be
surprised and and and I say that because
he's um you know like like AdSense is
based on how ad friendly you are that's
why uh like my main YouTube channel is
very low the CPM which is the how much
you get per thousand views like I'm uh
edgy and Roman Atwoods is through the
roof because he's kidfriendly right
right he's family friendly so I think
that uh so you think he took an L I mean
I don't may you know what maybe I'm I'm
converted maybe you're right especially
because with all of Cat Williams history
of just being arrested like time and
time again like violence I think he had
like guns like
crazy one thing after another he was
just like constantly in trouble and
doing very well in his career despite
that fact so do you think him doing
something like this gets him blackballed
from doing like major Motion Pictures he
he said he's was been in 60 movies
according to IMDb it checks out um I
mean he pays people out of his own
pocket he's adopted seven kids I mean
there's adopted seven kids yeah he's got
seven kids adopted I mean the the amount
of stories that came out on him on like
yeah dude like I was struggling and like
dude somebody came up and handed me like
a t-shirt wrapped up and he's like a
front row at at his seat and there was
like a struggling comedian and he's like
Oh I thought it was just a bunch of weed
and he's like it came back it was 15
grand Richie reading has nothing but
good things to say about him yeah I mean
the he said he bought a a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame put 75 grand in
for some some singer that uh you know
he's like during that time like she got
hated on because of the color of her
skin he's like he bought her the star I
mean I mean he's a Bonafide
lunatic being a Bonafide lunatic can
either be a good thing or a bad thing
but it is a very bad thing when you are
a lunatic by choosing to wear clothing
that damages the environment that's made
in factories that treats people poorly
and people that's why outerknown is so
important this is Kelly Slater the goat
of Surfing Kelly Slater the most epic
dude ever started this company because
he wanted to make clothes that you're
not a lunatic for wearing clothes that
are made with Organic sustainable stuff
in factories that treat people well and
clothes that look good I'm wearing them
right now and I'll tell you the people
who listen to The Wild Ride podcast as
well as my personal friends get
25% off when they go to
outerknown.com
sto that's o u
t k n
wn.com steo and make sure you use the
promo code steo to enjoy again
25% off your order and you can feel
really good about it because it's
organic sustainable stuff made in
factories that treat people well one
more time outerknown.com steo and use
the promo code steo for 25% off your
order and you can thank Kelly Slater for
that now let's get back to
it I think what cat so I don't think he
necessarily cares and to answer your
question did he get blackballed he's
been blackballed right why he's lashing
out like that well he he he's been black
balled because they said he was
difficult to work with but then his his
reasoning was like well I'm just not
going to you know yeah wear a
dress there was a point before uh Suge
Knight went to prison Suge Knight was
like all of a sudden acting as his
manager some weird thing really yeah put
Suge Knight and Cat Williams sug Knight
has a podcast that he does from jail
from a pay phone no he does
not yeah it's called Uh yeah look that
up uh if that's true that's epic cat
Williams said his arrest alongside Suge
Knight in
2014 wasn't what it
appeared hey look up uh Su Knight's
podcast that is just really really
funny um collect calls with calls with
SH KN EP how many how many subscribers
have
collect breakbeat media I that's pretty
epic he's probably got some to say
wow wow such a good name too that's a
really good name for prison
podcast um you made a lot of collect
calls from prison uh I mean I was never
in prison I was in county jail and uh I
I made some calls Who you calling in
prison in jail whoever you know like I
like I was in jail for my dad's birthday
in uh 1996 and I never had ever forgot
my dad's birthday it's the one time I
didn't call my dad on his birthday
because I didn't have the heart for him
to pick up the phone and and hear you're
receiving a call from inmate in
directional facility so uh I just acted
as if I forgot his birthday that year
yeah would you did you ever tell him
that like that's the reason why I I died
many many years later many many years
later uh yeah he didn't know I was in
jail um but in any case so uh to answer
your question no I don't think that Cat
Williams
career suffers because of this because
like you know any um issues that it
would cause have already been caused is
my guess yeah um it does benefit him and
now he goes on Rogan like uh Kevin Hart
took the high road saying I hope his
career kills it and this that you know
and like it's it's a case where
negative publicity is actually good
publicity he went after Steve Harvey oh
my God he went after everybody Steve
Harvey Cedric the
Entertainer uh ludic like Tiffany hadish
Kevin har ludicrous um teraji oh maybe
he didn't go after her maybe he
supportive I don't know it was insane
all right
um well uh well can we I okay so Aon
Rogers took the
L Rogers took the L for sure yeah is
Aaron Rogers
attractive I used to think so I don't
think so all right what's your type
Autumn it's so I don't even know how to
answer this I don't have a type well
what attracted you to Vinnie you know
what it wasn't that he thinks it is it's
not it wasn't his eyes he always says
it's the eyes it's not the eyes that
wasn't no but he loves say that it's the
eyes it wasn't the eyes what was it um I
don't know initially so we met on
Instagram who slid in the who DM he did
but I kind of initiated it I'll admit
that what did he say no no no no he said
he she was she we're okay I I going to
tell the truth okay um he popped up on
my Explorer page and I don't follow like
a lot of stunt things or a lot of stuff
like that but I just saw like this guy
back flipping into fire and I was like
oh that's cool so I clicked on it and I
saw he had tattoos it was the tattoos
first that's what it was first like oh
he's got a lot of tattoos um and then I
don't know I was just looking on I was
just creeping and it was more just like
your personality I was like oh he's like
really funny it just I I felt like you
were very transparent that's what it was
um but like physical it was your smile I
really liked your smile that's what the
first thing was it wasn't the eyes all
right W it was can I say and then you
got then he took you out on the first
date yeah where did he take you uh I
forgot the name it was in Malibu was
this really good restaurant in Malibu
called Sunset were you impressed I was
impressed I was he actually so um we
talked on FaceTime for a few weeks
before we met cuz I was in Canada um and
then I had come up to LA and the first
10 minutes of the car he didn't say
anything he was shy like he didn't speak
I was talking and talking and talking he
was like oh yeah yeah like we I you're
like a completely different person a St
I was really shy you so shy like
wouldn't even like look me in the eye
just so yeah it was really nice okay
yeah we I think
before you guys uh
started dating we had discussed on the
podcast that Vinnie like just to our
shocking surprise like has like been
really popular with like wild attractive
women I saw it I saw it that's almost
what turned me off cuz I was like oh
great he's like really out there I was
like she thought I was a cheater yeah I
thought not a cheater yeah no definitely
not a cheer I thought you were a player
okay so
that I want to be I want to be a little
candid
here um I I've I've I I I haven't said
anything a resentment been harboring a
resentment towards Vinnie oh boy okay
yeah because when we had Knoxville on
the podcast first two minutes of the
podcast I explained to Knoxville that uh
since the last time he was on that I've
really put effort into into cultivating
better conversational etiquette not
interrupting people letting people speak
and and I said I think I've gotten I
think I've gotten better and Vinnie's up
there he
goes I'm like I'm like wait what like I
mean I've really I have been really
trying I think I've gotten really better
you have you've gotten a little better
not greatly better not like really
really bad she's doubling down wow it
dude it made for a good
riff and I'm just like oh God like that
that's the one episode where we know
every single one of our vers and it's in
the first two minutes of the episode if
any's over here be like yeah you suck
you suck your show sucks you suck well I
mean I mean I think I think what the E
meant was like you got an 80% better
yeah n and you're taking the eh to mean
15% better all right I'd say 70% better
all right yeah I'd say 90 I mean it we
don't need to go overboard over here
okay you just cut me
off okay but but that's got nothing to
do with anything and uh you just had to
steer that towards
you when we're talking about Autumn and
Vinnie right I was joking around with
Isaac saying like oh man I want to let
Vinnie have it because I'm so mad about
the KN something I'm not mad and I don't
want to let you have it um but you
[Music]
I don't want to damn I
didn't know you were a little upset
about that I mean I was like do I wasn't
I didn't know either I didn't I didn't
think anything of it yeah I didn't
either like there was a lot of laughter
after that yeah I mean it was funny but
it was a burn
okay okay but I will justify anything
that uh this is just going to be juicy
right here yeah okay when we got to
England yes when we landed in England
yes you were very quiet very withdrawn
yes very sad yes because you had
received a a call or had a conversation
with Autumn yes where she explained that
your relationship was over oh yeah I
remember
that actually that popped in my head the
other day and I got really mad about it
and I was like I'm not going to do that
I just well what can let's hear from
Autumn what happened okay yeah sure okay
so I I'm someone when I start dating
someone I'm very transparent about
things that I like things I don't like
in relationships and you know I I just
air it all out cuz my thing is like from
that you can be like okay you know I
this isn't going to work for me I don't
want to be with you you know maybe I
have these habits or I do these things
so I just like to tell someone you know
um I like you know I like flowers and I
don't like when you like girls Instagram
pictures so I was very you know so he
did the flowers thing he always sent me
flowers he was very nice um but I did
notice from like the beginning of us
talking to like getting into dating I
would see his follower number go up a
lot and I was
like okay the people who he is following
he following yeah and it was always like
Instagram girls you know yeah like like
the fitness accounts with 12 million
followers yeah and so as I understood it
Autumn you said to Vinnie like hey it
bothers me when you follow porn stars
and like their posts set a healthy
boundary how about this young lady
setting and maintaining healthy
boundaries which actually proved to
nourish and grow a healthy relationship
with Vinnie it's a beautiful thing and I
also think that it's very important to
nourish and grow a healthy business with
healthy boundaries and that's where ship
station comes in man ship station is the
way to grow your business online by
selling stuff to your audience like say
for example autographed Skyjack
skateboards and I'm really happy to have
these available one more time because
the bucket list special has been so much
fun to share and to promote and
everybody's just everybody's loving
skyjacking so everybody can now go to
sto.com and enjoy this this and you know
what they can receive it because of ship
station it's just this one interface
that brings together all the different
carriers like FedEx UPS United States
Postal Service and all the different
ways you can sell if it's for me sto.com
maybe you sell on Amazon Etsy eBay
doesn't matter all in one interface
you've got all of your e-commerce
working for you with the cheapest rates
available and it's all just so easy it
just prints out the label boom put it on
the box it's out the door you're killing
it with e-commerce you're growing and
nourishing a healthy business and it's
all because of shipstation plus they'll
give you 30 days free trial if you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
steo nothing to lose 30-day free trial
it's time to make ship happen and grow
your business so go to shipstation.com
use the promo code steo and happy
selling everybody now let's get back to
it post yeah and then like and then it
it continues after you said that you had
a problem with that a a couple times it
continued a few more times couple we
just heard it was once no it continued a
few times and it wasn't like he was like
messing like it wasn't anything like
that like you were not again you're not
like a cheater but he just kept doing it
like um so I got mad CU I was like I'm
someone if I like initiate a boundary
like if someone tells me they're not
comfortable with something then I'm like
I won't do it I won't do it right um so
he kept doing it so um on top of that he
didn't like text me right away when he
got to London so that made me mad too
cuz I was like I know you're there like
you're not texting me so in my head I
was like oh he's following all these
girls he's like whatever I was just
spiraling so I was like you know what
like if that's something you like to do
if you like to follow these accounts and
consume it that's fine but you're not
going to do it when you're with me I
don't think it was unfair I don't think
not all it was 100% like the most
rational healthy boundary and and Vinnie
was it wasn't like it just came out of
nowhere I wasn't like right you know if
that was something that I never
discussed and then I just broke up it's
like okay well you never express cuz
some people don't care about that in
relationship you want to know what he
ate after you broke up with them what
what I came down to the lobby and he's
eating the whole pizza and a
gallon of ice cream and I'm like Jesus
Christ dude what are you eating mind you
eight hours before that he's like I'm on
a diet
I'm he he was absolutely devastated like
it was the the harshest thing and all he
had to say for himself was like dude
like all I did was like a photo did not
just like a photo he followed like half
of the population of Instagram models I
was like yeah he he wasn't defending
himself he was just like he's just like
I can't help it like I see a hot chick I
I I hit follow double tap like I can't
just like you know doesn't mean anything
by it I just like I just can't help it
like I see it I like
it that's that's what I get but like my
thing is too like I see how dude's on
Instagram all the time but in my brain
it's like as a girl point if I go and
look at who's following me I assume that
it's if it's a do the interest like you
see my Instagram I'm not posting like
pictures of me at the library so if
you're following me then you know that's
obviously what so to me it's like if
someone's in a relationship if you see
someone that's attractive cool she's
attractive just keep swiping okay but
are dudes dming you yeah are you
responding um no I haven't there was
this um I always tell you like there's
this one guy that was in a band and I
was like I he dm' me like this is so
cool so I like responded I'm like oh
thanks like yeah I love your music and
then he said oh send me a text sometime
and I never answered but I I tell him
everything I always tell him I'm like I
feel like I tell you too much cuz
sometimes I go into detail I don't want
to know but it's just my conscience like
I if I'm something pops in my head or
something happens I'm like I need to
tell you you gotta behave at all times
as though your significant other is
watching on like a special surveillance
cam so that yeah everything you do is
always like respectful of your
significant yeah yeah Isaac brought up
Jeremy Rogers cuz he was one of the
dudes that was hitting her up oh wow wow
I never I never answered
him who who was the guy in the band can
you say um can you just say the name of
the band can I say that well he's not
he's like a solo musician I don't know
if I can I
don't just start F okay I'm so excited
about that we don't we don't need to
worry about that um but um he's been
better since then oh yeah yeah I think
that was like the wakeup call of me
being like this is actually boundary
like this is actually ticking me off
like you're not this is Breer yeah
because what it is dude it's like I'm
it's like such it was second nature for
me for so long to just like and
sometimes not even look at the screen
I'm just like oh yeah not even looking
because you're so busy looking at your
zipper Jesus I think that's what makes
me mad is when guys are like but I I
don't even look at my phone when I'm
liking it how are you liking it you're
not looking at your phone do you guys
have access to each other's phones yeah
you don't go on mine but I look on yours
yeah good I think that's not anymore but
and I have our face recognition our we
used to have our thumb print we share
locations yeah we share locations he's
the first guy I've ever done that with
um I've never done that before but good
I I like that I think it's healthy yeah
but in terms of like trust like we don't
have issues with that that was a
boundary
and it made me mad got over it that
problem has been resolved yes my know
it's been resolved to her I don't look
anymore I don't know I feel like I
should look now right no I mean I I
believe I believe that it has and I
don't have any question about Vinnie's
dedication to you I believe that Vinnie
faithful to you I think that that like
he's profoundly grateful he's clearly a
lucky guy to be with you yeah and and
and that's all good what could
be looked at as concerning I'll just
give an example when uh you went to
Vegas for your first time ever we all we
all went out on this trip to Las Vegas
you'd never seen it and you'd think like
here's this is Vinnie's opportunity to
to show you something you've never seen
before to take you on a romantic date to
go like Walk The Strip see the sites and
Vinnie treated you to a trip to a shoe
store so that you could watch him by
himself yeah yeah I remember that it was
actually you that said it too you're
like why are you not bringing her out to
go do these things you got a hot chick
on your arm in Vegas and you take her to
go yourself a pair of
shoes hey babe this place they got sick
hype hype beasts in
balances hype beast in dude all right
I'm not going to okay listen I would I'm
not going to make up excuses and try to
justify any of this whatsoever but
but it I've never really been in a
relationship with somebody who I like
genuinely care about right for like ever
honestly you know what I mean so it's
like I really
laughing so you would think that this
being your first time you'd be
overwhelmed with just a helicopter ride
around the Grand Canyon dude
hey Steve you Tex Gordon Ramy for me to
get me into Hell's Kitchen
you're not making a good argument it's
like this is the first time like I
can't the first time about she's all I
think about all I want to do is just
take go watch me buy a pair of shoes I
was going to buy her a pair too I was I
asked her I asked her she says no I
don't wear these are the first Nikes
that I have and they're because of you
he bought a year later he bought me
shoes okay now on the topic of your hype
Beast shoe habit yeah is it alarming or
concerning to you Autumn what a
disproportional amount of
Vinnie's funds income income is allotted
is allotted to his hype Beast end
balances and his dunks and his like
right like I mean I I'll argue on this
one all day I do not I do not spend a
crazy amount of money on shoes everybody
thinks so I mean it's hard to imagine
you do spend a lot but I mean as long as
we have like a house in the car yeah I
make sure I have a good amount of money
in my savings account I make sure the
bills are paid I make sure there's food
in the fridge I make sure everything is
good hey hey and and if your
ladies quot it then yeah I don't like I
spend I really I don't spend money like
you know I don't right I don't um but I
like spending money like I read a lot of
books so a lot of my things so if he
were to make me feel bad about why like
that's a stupid hobby you know I mean it
is a little more productive than shoes
but I if he were to make me feel bad
about that I'd be like well that's
something I like to do and it makes me
happy so I don't make him feel bad if I
again if I was noticing like our funds
were just really low but do you have an
eye on that do you have like do you know
what your funds are have you guys like
we haven't opened a book no we haven't
but she could look at my phones anytime
she want no no but like I mean she she
can look at his FS there in his closet
yeah I can do that but isn't that like
something that's important for like a
like two becomes one so you guys are
going to yeah mingle funds yeah
absolutely and are you better are you
better at spending money or is Vinnie
better at spending money no I I really
don't spend money I she's so low
maintenance it's crazy and are you high
in maintenance he's so high my mom even
says she always ask me what the wedding
she's like how's the future bride doing
and I'm like oh I'm good she's like no
not you
Vinnie man just wants all these things
he was trying to rent like a Rolls-Royce
for the wedding I was like you don't cuz
it would look sick in pictures I know
like an old school oldfashioned
Rolls-Royce for a few hours you know
sick yeah um so uh but we want to make
sure this marriage lasts so is there
anything that Vinnie does that like you
don't like that we can like air out now
that you guys are arguing about because
like I feel like you got a catch here
Vinnie I know I do you don't want to
it up and I feel like I'm going to
say you know when we did the big shoot
at my house I was going to bring that up
too but you probably cuz you weren't
even there for this part of I heard
about this when I gave you a call I
called you directly and I said hey man
like it sounds like you were uh you know
egregiously lacking self-awareness and
in and very inconsiderate of your lady
when we had this shoot at the house are
you picking up on social cues from your
girl when she's on the couch like
and you're like what dud I got I have to
go into the jacuzzi and get my for 15
minutes but I went I was going into the
jacuzzi while the footage was dropping
the footage was dropping footage was
dropping the footage was dropping I got
to get in the jacuzzi for my 15 minutes
of me
time yeah I just want 15 minutes of
myself you took no no no no no no okay
listen best friend in town listen no no
no no I was going in and out of the ju
jacuzzi while the footage was dropping
and then also the footage waso 11
minutes ago and I had a business meeting
a little thing that I was doing I was
supposed to go do that never happened
yeah thank God I had a business meeting
and I just had to get my 15 minutes in
me be ready for it okay I'm not like I'm
not going to make excuses or
justification for like my shitty actions
but but but but Autumn like but that's
not the only time this has happened
right right no it it was a consistent
thing I always say at the beginning of
the relationship I'm not going to lie it
was like I had a very hard time not
because you're like oh no no no not cuz
you're like a horrible boyfriend but
like you just you haven't been in
relationships like at all they've been
like two months you know so I just it's
hard to be with someone like that who
hasn't been in relationships because
they really lack like that
self-awareness and they're like at times
they can be selfish because they're not
used to being you know but I'm someone
like I've been in like foure
relationships I've lived with people you
know what I mean so I've have that so I
know like not to be selfish but he just
didn't really but I think genuinely the
last time like when you called when it
was like coming from a third party like
looking up being like dude like that's I
think that's when it was kind of his
wakeup call um because there's times
where it would get better and then you
know it would decline um but I think
like someone else being like this is you
know well see like I am a
particularly self-absorbed like you know
and and I know how much work
that I have to do for my relationship
everyone does yeah perfect just
kid just
kidding totally kidding I I know I just
know how how much I come up short and
and I'm aware of it I strongly believe
that it is important to know when you
come up short and to do something about
it and sadly I have to admit one more
time that I have come up short and how
do I know that I know that because I
wear a whoop band you see today I have
only burned
1,917 calories so far and it's after
1000 p.m. as I speak right now that is
pathetic with the kind of recovery I got
last night the kind of sleep I mean I
got uh oo only 87% of my sleep
performance goal but that's no excuse
for my strain being as low as it is and
these are statistics information that
help me know when I got to push a little
harder and man there's no other Fitness
tracking device that's going to give you
anywhere near as much insight into
what's going on with your body and your
health then whoop all of the awesomest
people wear it because it's the
awesomest thing to wear and you can get
10% off you're whole deal at whoop.com
that's
wh.com if you use the promo code steo
and you're going to know when you come
up short like I'll tell you this
yesterday I didn't come up short at all
yesterday I burned
3,391
calories and that's called beast mode
and I know that because I wear a whoop
band so if you want to get on the whoop
train then go to whoop.com and use the
promo code steo and you're going to get
10% off at checkout it's a good call man
I strongly recommend it so jump on the
whoop train and let's get back to
it you know and so I know that it takes
a lot of work and so my concern with
Vinnie was that like he's not even
necessarily aware of it you know yeah
you know yeah and you're right at the
time I really wasn't that aware of it
but now it's the new Vinnie yes all
right so does autumn do anything that
that bugs you no I really don't think so
no sorry I'm GNA answer so don't
this up I I know okay let me ask you
this she let me say this she puts up
with my very well and she
understands that um like the goals that
I have and dreams that I have and she
lets me do all these things
without question yeah and that means
more to me than anything you know so
I'm I'm a head sometimes are you
going to cry at your wedding I don't
know he's going to cry I have a that
he's going to cry on the alar he is a
cry you're a lot more emotional than I
am yeah I'm very emotional for sure okay
so then I have to ask this I'm sorry
because we're beating up on Vinnie what
happens once you guys get married oh
yeah I don't know you say that on
YouTube what happened to you can I say
uh what happens to your side
hustle side hustle yeah oh you guys
don't know the lady I'm actually like
kind of retired I retired recently yeah
I deleted um both of my pages that I was
using um I don't I just wasn't happy
doing it anymore I wasn't feeling it I
feel like how much money was coming in
from that it was like a good few grand a
month right so when I was doing the
first site it was a lot because they
were paying me to be on the app as well
on top of that um and then the second
site it was kind of more just extra
money I wasn't really putting a lot into
it and then when I kind of reflected
like well why am I not putting lot into
it I just wasn't happy doing it just I
felt like more of like a chore and that
kind of thing um and I felt like I
wasn't really showing anyone like what I
wanted to show like I like I know it's a
touchy subject on this podcast but I
like playing video games and that kind
of we're good with
it I'm a
gamer what do you like cod and stuff
yeah okay so cool um so I like I want
people to like know about me like I like
playing video games and I like doing
like YouTube and that kind of thing and
I just feel like what I was doing wasn't
really like in my interests so yeah I
just like impulsively I just deleted it
good so that's gone yeah what how are
you making money um I do social media
management for a company yeah so it's
all from home so I just manage like
their like Facebook Instagram all their
socials and stuff wow good for you you
yeah I got a keeper you do you have more
than a keeper I know I know you do and
uh does Vinnie
snore okay you know what makes me so
upset is that at the beginning of our
relationship I was like oh it's so nice
being with someone who doesn't snore
like I get all these peaceful sleeps as
soon as he like proposes and I say yes I
swear to God that night he starts
snoring like that and I was like okay
it'll pass as just one night and for the
last however long we've been engaged
every single night never though at the
beginning never you never snored is it
time for a sleep study to see if you
need a seat I think he I think he does
dud yeah yeah like I move into into the
living room and sleep on the couch
sometimes just so and he gets mad at me
I don't get mad you do no I don't you're
like like you're waking me up from
hitting me and like whatever cuz I'll
nudge him and I'm like oh I'm sorry like
okay
now Vinnie uh intermittently gets pretty
dedicated to eating better and losing
weight and stuff like where are you at
like with with Vinnie's weight do you
like do you uh chime in do you say like
oh you know like I love you the way you
are like it's okay like or you know like
hey you maybe get on a treadmill like my
thing like with anyone as long as I see
someone being productive like he's 10
times more active than me like he wakes
up in the morning goes for walks goes to
the gym I started getting into it
because it's like important to him it's
part of his routine and that kind of
thing um but if I noticed anyone like no
matter what size they were like not
taking care of themselves and just
whatever I would chime in but like he
goes to the gym every day he goes for
walks he eats super healthy like you
really don't eat bad you eat super
healthy very well uh for he only eats
calories no I've been doing sweet tooth
every now and then Rec recently what
you've been eating healthy yes the past
few weeks but like here's the thing with
Vinnie he's so confident and
like borderline delusional that I think
he creates this reality that like like
he's actually because he'll be like dude
I haven't eaten anything bad and then
he'll literally go walk into the cabinet
and just start eating
and I'm like Vinnie you just said he's
like it's the only time but like it
happens like five or six times a day at
home I don't know what he does here but
at home I will say that he eats good
because he's like dude I ate healthy I
put I had I had oatmeal and I
sprinkled brown sugar all over it and
then I had a bagel with locks and cream
get the out of here right
no dude one thing I'm going to tell him
about the Jelly Bean thing it's really
funny so a few weeks ago um you weighed
yourself and he just like wasn't happy
so he's like okay no more sweets until
the wedding like nothing I'm not kidding
two hours later he comes in with a
handful of jelly beans and like I was
like oh can I have some he's like no and
he just ate all them and he's like he
forgot that he said that that's what I'm
saying he for he forgot he's like oh I
forgot that I said that hours ago I
think he it's like this like
delusional reality
that he lives in he's my favorite person
in the world I'm not trying to on
him he's my top four favorite person in
the world but like but like you he's
like dude I don't spend any money on
clothes and then he'll come to Steve the
next day yeah or like shopping bags and
we're like me and Isaac look at each
other and we're like dude you just said
you didn't shop he's like dude this is
my once a month where I'm able to
shop right Isaac help me out here Isaac
say something I mean we we I think we
all love Vinnie more than like anybody
in the world because he's such a just
Beautiful
Disaster he's just such an
absolute oh man yeah I mean you're
Classic you're Classic you're so
hilarious because like you know like
you're Vinnie yeah I mean I couldn't be
more happy that like it was gradual
Vinnie like kind of like you know
coming into the picture and like you
know he was behind the scenes and just
and then more and more it's like dude
he's classic yeah I love Vinnie being
being on the mic I I think that all of
your contributions to the episodes are
are are Stellar I think that your
dedication to to my team the he's r or
die that's the one thing I really like
found attractive about him is he's just
so like ride or die and just so reliable
and consistent
yeah he's ride or die and uh it's
hilarious and we're all rooting
for you guys thanks dude thank you I
don't think I have anything else that I
would want to even like you know poke at
but like I I I pledge to speak up if I
see him acting like a schmuck I've
already done it thank you yeah I'll do
it again say hey dude like don't be
blowing it you know like you've been
yeah I was listening to uh the the guy
Patrick Bet David talk about like what's
the key to a SE successful marriage and
it was something along the lines of like
if you were to call or his five closest
friends and your five closest friends
like if uh if you called one of those
girls and were like Vinnie da d
d da they should have his back the same
as if Vinnie if Vinnie were to call us
and vent about something like you we
would give him yeah so it's like
you know what I mean he said that's the
kind of people you should surround
yourself with like and we all have your
back because we want this to work yeah
it's going to take a
community yeah yeah yeah last question
before we get to our bucket list winner
yeah
um does he satisfy you in bed he does I
will say lately there's been a little
lasting problem oh wow lasting yeah dude
wa you come too quick come quick too
quick but but at first it's like you're
too long and now it's too quick how
quick like a minute like a minute dude
that's pretty that's pretty crazy it
seems like the other way around I wish I
could last a minute I mean it's got to
be that's got to be flattering it's
flattering but it's also like do
something this like a one minute and
then he starts snoring
yeah dude at first I
dude 20 30 it was too long at first yeah
30 minutes and then what she just and
then lately figured it out lately it's
just been really quick yeah he has no
shame in it too he just lays there like
he's been shot and he's like oh that was
great a minute of cardio he's then he
doesn't do anything to to satisfy you
not lately just not lately look look I I
I I had no no no no no no no no no no
hold on a second here hold on I've had
this conversation with you I was like I
think my testosterone levels are because
we're not even having that much sex
lately you have like the libido of like
a sloth I don't know I know I don't know
what I don't know what it is I haven't
had the I think a stress is a lot a big
part of it I haven't had energy I had my
sex drive isn't there right now um why
why is it goingon to be there later no I
no so pound yeah the past few weeks I've
been I I finally got my routines back
I've been finally eating better I'm back
in the gym I have my my schedules and
I've been feeling better mentally and
physically so okay what here's here's a
suggestion and I'll even like just spill
this out about about Lux and I and our
intimate Affairs like
I fairly
regularly like our program is
I go downtown I go downtown and and and
I I uh I just bury my face where it
needs to to be buried until she's gotten
where she needs to get after you come no
no no no no cuz after I come
I'm start start out start out I go down
there and I get it done completely until
she has collected been paid in full yeah
yeah and that like once we get to that
point like that's kind of what turns me
on so once
she's arrived at her final disc
destination then I'm like all right now
I'm just totally ready so now let's try
something you know like I know I mean
look when I when we were first together
first few months like I was on and ready
to go all day every day yeah it was
great yeah and then I think like then
now I'm just over
it you son of a
no dude I
I never dude never I I just I don't know
there's just I'm super stressed when If
he if he goes downtown yeah does he have
any skills in that department yeah oh
yeah like I finish like every time like
every time there's never been like any
yeah so why not start the the ceremonies
that that's what I've been saying for
the last two months two months it's been
a rough two months two months D you
don't want the rough you're getting
married this weekend
know two months not two months the night
of our wedding she can tell you the
exact date it started probably not two
months I can no what prob about the LA
like the last week of November when I
noticed it was like going a little rocky
wait the last time we had sex no not the
last time we had se but L started going
a little the last time I was any
good the last time we had sex was like
boxing
day sounds like the 26th of December is
the last time you done things since then
but it was Boxing Day what's Boxing Day
it's the 26th of December oh oh you
haven't had sex in 3 weeks no we haven't
at the house we've done like stuff but
we haven't done we haven't because every
night he's like oh yeah we're going to
do it and then he's like either just
snoring by the time I get there or I I
go down there and then you're just oh
she goes down there I I yes as much as
he will allow me because he wow I I like
doing it she as much as much as you
allow it all day every day I don't know
what you're talking please admit that I
do do it a lot yeah of course yeah okay
so can can we get a commitment from you
that you'll go down of course tonight I
love going down you have sex tonight yes
sure absolutely if you love it so much
then why is it I'm just I'm exhausted
I'm so tired I love it love let her get
on top you don't have to do anything I
know that's what yeah I know I'm she'll
be on top for like less than a minute
pretty much pretty much I can't believe
you all rightz dude all right I mean can
can we just commit to making sure she
arrives at her destination before you
board the train of course yes thank you
I appreciate that that's going be the
key to a longlasting marriage yes all
right well we uh with with that I think
I'm pretty comfortable to to not have to
speak up at the the
actual God yeah say speak now we forever
hold your peace and I think I've raised
all my concerns I think I'm satisfied
good yeah I'm glad how about you Scott
yeah good I'm good I I've felt like I
said everything I needed to say yeah and
I can't wait for this weekend all right
and here's what a trooper Vinnie is we
have so many goddamn podcasts in and
around his wedding that he's doing them
all you know what I mean are you doing
not the Chris Angel one yeah are you GNA
do that too the day after I want him to
yeah she's a big
which one which one would you rather not
do like I want him to I'm just so over
this
guy he's not even eat my on a
wedding
night what what which podcast would you
like to not get out of or would you like
to get out of for your wedding anything
after Chris Angel I think that's it yeah
so you aren you doing you're doing uh
hopefully have like two or three more P
or something yeah yeah all right well
you let us know yeah no stress yeah and
uh
thank you Autumn yeah thanks for being
here Autumn yeah thanks forks and now
everybody um when I released and
promoted my bucket list special I
announced on my social media pages that
I was GNA fulfill somebody's bucket list
uh wish and and people submitted there
was one guy who uh is um terminally ill
and trying to to set World Records in
raising money to uh for cancer research
and his his uh request was that he be on
the Wild Ride podcast and this guy I
mean dude the video he made is classic
and he was by far in a way the winner so
um let's get to it and ladies and
gentlemen Ian Ward The Bucket List
winner and Ian
one with this fantastic hilarious and
emotional
submission where he explained that he he
has terminal brain cancer that right
that's correct I like your description
of it makes it seem as all like I'm a
jiujitsu expert that it's like this
emotional submission where like yeah
what's that film The Warrior where he's
like breaking his arm and he's telling
his brother I love you
man
OT submission that's me all over it
genuinely was by far and way the most
compelling uh submission to uh the
contest of all and what was particularly
fascinating is that I
re-shared your uh Instagram reel to my
stories with you distinctive
distinctively uh tagged
copied and and you didn't even
acknowledge
it homeboy over here not checking his uh
DMS at all I'm like yo where you at
and crickets and then then Isaac Isaac
was like dm' you like hey like like you
win crickets that's why it's been like
literally like two months with no winner
you're not not you might actually not
have been the only person that this has
happened to um are you I know you're
into UFC but did you ever follow
WWE uh I've not followed WWE
doesn't matter there's a there's someone
in it and her name is Becky Lynch and um
Becky Lynch went to the same school as
me I think she was a year below the year
that my brother was in so we have loads
of actual sort of friends that are all
on Instagram together and Becky sent me
a video uh about two or sent me a
message about two years ago just saying
like hey I see your go up on social
media and blah blah blah blah and Becky
Lynch's like if you go to buy h the
video games for WWE she's on the cover
so she's big time and it was
only by the look that I was flicking
through the uh the like the um the spam
folder for uh DMS on Instagram and I
found her there it's like she's got a a
Blue Tick recognized and it's like why
is this coming into the spam and what
she said was like uh like quite
um um I wouldn't say emotional but like
it was quite a person message she was
like ah Ian I remember you running
around the halls of Mount Tempa like a
lunatic and clearly nothing's
changed so like it wasn't like it was
you know quite a spammy thing and
somehow it just ended up there and I
imagine that's probably what happened
with yourself yeah um that was a
um Ian's long version of I'm Shadow
baned
bro like uh I think uh Instagram has a
um a prejudice D Ming then yeah well no
it's uh it's it's on you buddy any
anybody else I get you right away
Instagram is prejudiced against
terminally ill
people can we just like go back to that
though like what you have so you have a
brain tumor yep and how did you find out
you had a brain tumor I found out I had
a brain tumor because uh I like money
but I don't like working to get it so uh
I would only ever still I guess I still
still only do jobs that I love doing and
uh so I was doing not that much work and
then so I started making myself into
human guinea pig and uh so I was going
in to do uh clinical trials and
basically they pay me shitloads of money
to um you know do whatever tests are
going on and contrary to what you would
see in like The Simpsons where you know
bar turns into a monster because he's
drinking new kind of cola or something
uh the amount of testing that they do is
so so carefully do they test it on
animals before they test it on humans
when they test it on humans they do tiny
doses so as a student it was a great way
to get a lot of money for absolutely no
work and uh it's actually ended up um
saving my life because um when I went in
they always do loads of tests to make
sure that you are a healthy person that
you can't actually take the tolerance of
whatever they're going to throw at you
and they were this time they were doing
a particular test that was H to do with
brain function so they did an MRI and
somehow that the timing of when they
wanted that particular H testing which
doesn't normally have an MRI an MRI is
expensive to um to operate they saw that
I had a tumor and so they said yeah this
looks like it's benign but you got to
get this checked out again and my first
reaction to that wasn't like oh my God
I'm in Peril blah blah blah it was it
was me going uh can I still get on the
test and they were like h no you cannot
get on the test you in serious a serious
medic condition I was like okay no going
to Peru on a you know an expensive
holiday then with my my friends AR like
that they're like ah no you need to get
this checked out again and then when I
got a check the second time um this was
kind of JK during Co so there was a big
break between um uh the first test and
the second test and then they were like
oh no this is not benign this has
actually grown a fair bit so this is
likely to be cancerous we got to get the
uh the ice cream scoop out and get it as
much as possible and so it was my
decision to either like do that or not
go into the surgery and the risks are
far higher not to do chemo the risks are
far higher so pardon the pun but it was
a no-brainer for me so went in and then
had the surgery and then um afterwards
uh because I during Co I had actually
set up a a social media account just so
I could play video games and it be
somewhat productive rather than just
spending loads of time doing all
hey I I support that video I'm I'm a big
supporter of video
games sorry for interrupting funny
enough when I was doing my own little
research for this I was like H one of
the last videos that I watched it was
about youo about how like you had been
on a gaming podcast went tits up or
something yeah yeah I uh I'm never going
to do that
again so so if I heard you correctly you
had brain
surgery uh yeah it was a I wouldn't
recommend it there it's like you know
I'm pretty sure well thinking about like
who I'm talking to here realistically I
Reon you've gone through more unpleasant
things than that to be perfectly honest
because but they had to keep you awake
right it lasted pardon they had to keep
you awake while your brain was no being
mushed up yeah no well it's a choice
it's a it's an obvious choice for anyone
who has any kind of you know will to
live properly but uh the choice was to
uh either do it awake uh which is
unpleasant you're also your your brain
doesn't actually have a nervous system
so like when they're poking around in
there it's not painful sawing into your
school that's that's not
pleasant it's like being caught in a
vice in that scene in Casino where like
um what's his name GNA pop someone's
Charlie M I'm gonna pop your head like a
grape yeah yeah it's a bit like
that um except my brain surgeon didn't
talk like Joe pesy boom it's gr okay so
so the surgery went well the surgery
went as well as it possibly could be uh
like during the surgery they were asking
me questions of like kind of H is this a
dog is this the cat and all they would
actually look out for is if you would
pause between saying that's a cat versus
uh that's a cat so yeah Serge you went
uh went as well as it could so Scott
Scott was correct you actually were
awake during the surgery oh yeah you can
have the choice to not be awake they can
put you under an anesthesia but if they
do that it means that they're poking
around in your brain tissue in the dark
whereas if you're awake when they are
asking you questions and you have that
pause that they have little prongs and
it's like they'll be pronging around and
if they're in a certain uh particular
area in the brain tissue and you are um
taking a moment to say a word that means
that it's active brain tissue whereas
most of your brain tissue that whole
thing with like Einstein where it's like
we only use 10% of our brain H and
people are like oh what if we could use
the whole 90% that's not really how the
brain works the brain is quite like an
actual room in a house and this room is
not you know 100% full of furniture if
it was 100% full of furniture you
wouldn't be able to move around so your
brain actually needs space to be able to
get around and deal with damages so they
would look for the space um in the brain
that's not being used and then they
would take that out so that's the the
bits of the tumor that they would try to
take out so if you're asleep they're
just taking as much out as as possible
and that's you know where people would
wake up and you know I had trouble uh
speaking after my uh surgery came about
but uh had I done that without be with
being asleep during the whole thing you
know I would have been woken up and not
being able to articulate my words
properly at all so I'm very glad I took
that option wow okay so so the
fascinating stuff there and you
had the surgery was successful but you
also had
chemo uh yeah that was um that was after
the chemo to be perfectly honest like
because it's brain cancer they can't hit
it hard with the
chemotherapy um so uh it was actually
fairly easy to go through people who
have like say lung cancer or breast
cancer that hits really hard they blast
you with that but uh brain cancer
they can't really blast the brain with
uh all the sort of heavy chemo and heavy
uh radio therapy because you
you hope it to turn you into a
vegetable so that's why you have your
beautiful locks of flowing
hair you can see it here now if you uh
if you turn my head to that side you can
see where the missing hairline is as
comparison to uh to this thing but how
long ago was that
surgery uh that surgery was two and a
half years ago okay now like the the
tough question like uh what they say I
saw in your trailer for your documentary
that they gave you like an estimated
three years to live at the time it was
five years and uh as soon the only
reason that I wanted that I was because
I had already started up doing the
Social Media stuff I kind of knew uh
that like I'd have to address um the
scar on the side of my head and that
like I'd raise some money for charity
while um sort of doing my live streams
and then when we were asking about the
dates it's not like uh Breaking Bad
where they give you a Set time uh out
there you got to really like try and
squeeze it out of them the doctors are
always like we don't know we don't know
we don't we don't want to give you a
number everybody's unique and I was like
nah no Noah come on come on come on come
on so I kind of knew that I was making
my way towards social media and that I
need a number to be able to sort of have
as a um a foundation so um they said all
right on average the life expectancy uh
for someone who went in with no symptoms
and blah blah blah blah blah is five
years um in and around the fiveyear mark
and then they were quick to jump in and
say however people who come in with no
symptoms meaning that I didn't have
headaches I wasn't getting dizzy I
wasn't like slurring my words or falling
over losing my balance people that don't
have symptoms and come in and get a a
brain scan are usually like twice my age
so the fact that you are young means
that you are in a completely unique
Realm uh our research might be accurate
um you might live for 5 years or you
might live for 10 we we really don't
know you might live for 20 and
so with that I was like okay I heard
five that's good enough that's the
biggest thing towards the sad story and
so um from that that is ex that's what I
was going for I was trying to fish it
out of them and then because I knew that
that is going to act like um an
emotional response it's going to get
more people to H have eyeballs on me and
uh um I think after my surgery no sorry
after they H we had that meeting I think
it was one week after that I had my
first video up where I made the decision
where it's like I am going to use this
against itself and I'm going to raise
the most amount of money ever for uh for
a charity for cancer research in this
case right and that brings us back to
the initial uh submission that you made
on Instagram saying that you wanted to
be on your bucket list request was to be
on the Wild Ride podcast to have us help
you to draw attention to your
fundraising effort to try to break the
world record for raising the most money
ever by running a marathon yep you got
that memorize way better than I
do I get ass at all the time and I
it up constantly how uh have you already
run the
marathon uh I have run several marathons
but it's a it's a thing where it's like
every year uh the uh the the attempt has
to be started again so it's kind of like
think about like seasons in uh you know
um football or basketball or something
like that right and and for the record
to count it's got to be uh a sum of
money that was raised for one particular
Marathon so all of you it's not the the
aggregate total of all of your marathons
it's got be for one so no so far we uh
like over the last couple of years we've
raised uh I think we calculated the
other day it's like
270,000 which is about a third of a
million um dollars so we're back down to
um zero this year however this year we
really think that it's going to be the
year where we're going to get it all the
way up to uh 2.9 uh million dollars in
one setting and I'm not the only which
which is which is the record sorry for
interrupting I just want to be clear be
clear to everybody the standing world
record for the most money raised by
running a marathon is 2. .9
million yeah do we know who I've
actually met the guy who um who has that
record good yeah he's a cool guy he's a
reverend and um he runs a charity over
in the UK and it was kind of this uh
weird sort of meeting that we were
having because he like he's uh he's like
I want you to break my record but then
it's like but then if you break my
record I'm got to break my record again
and he's like his record hasn't been
broken for like uh I think it's over 10
years and he's like uh I I want you to
do it but in another way it's like I
don't want to Ru any more marathons I'm
so tired of them like I'm in my 60s now
I'm bored of them and I was like you're
okay is is the record recognized by the
Guinness book yeah it is yeah okay hold
on a second I feel like I have to be the
voice of reason over here what kind of
brain cancer do you have I mean is it is
there a certain type of tumor it is
what's the
cause um uh I'm trying to think what's
the the um where can people go donate I
mean like is there a cure for this I
mean what stage of The Grieving cycle
are you in I I have like all these
questions that I think we're just fast
forwarding over sure uh well I think the
the biggest one there is uh how do
people donate and um they don't that's
my unique thing that's my sort of unique
selling point I get people to uh follow
my account if you go on to uh use the
username the king of King
all of the social media accounts I'm on
there and then when sponsors see hey
this guy's got loads of followers let's
you know give him some money to
advertise uh on his platform and then
the advertisement money I just take that
and throw it straight into the
um uh the cancer research puddle so it's
like
um how would I put
it it's like a a pyramid scheme except
it's not a scam kind of like that I I
wouldn't promote it that
way um but uh so you're trying to build
up your socials to get branding deals
and all that yeah yeah no we've done
well so far we've gotten uh uh support I
don't know do you guys have Jim shark
over in the US Jim shark I'm pretty sure
my protein is they're the current
biggest ones at the moment they've they
do 10,000 um uh Great British pounds
every month which is IID imagine it'd be
like about
13,000 US Dollars and now does 100% of
your brand deals go into the um the
research stuff 100% of all the yeah well
and not specifically cancer research
there's been previous ones where I did
for like a a children's charity then
there was another one for uh mental
health uh there was a um oh was
definitely one other charity that we
were done oh yeah sorry no movember is
what I'm thinking of which is also a
cancer research uh charity but yeah 100%
of all of it goes to a charity anyway
okay but at the moment uh uh we have the
American Cancer Society has actually uh
for this year in particular uh they
saying that it's all going to be going
into the American Cancer Society and one
of the big things that I'm very excited
about is that uh they have not only I
thought that they'd announced me as an
ambassador they've announced me as one
of their ch iions which is like like I
wear this Crown thing as a piss take
because it's catchy and it's sort of
visually someone would have a look at my
profile and kind of thing what the f
who's this wearing the crown and
then hear the story it's like oh okay
he's not only he's not up his own hole
as much as it would seem but like same
thing has happened with American Cancer
Society where it's like yes you are the
champion of our uh our charity cause was
like all right I'll take that I won't
say no to that that's great if if you're
donating 100% uh of all of the revenue
that you're bringing in from your brand
deals from your donations then like what
are you doing to feed yourself like uh
do are you do you have a
job uh no not anymore I used to be on uh
what's called in I think welfare that
used to be what I was on however once I
got the contract with um uh my protein
thankfully someone I know one of my
family members H they were getting on to
me was like e even if you are giving all
of that to uh charity because you are
still in control of it you have to come
off uh it's called Universal Credit over
here and then so uh I was kind of like
oh God how the am I going to pay
the rent and I simply just put on a
subscription list on my um Instagram and
straight away a lot of people were like
um uh subscribing to that and now I have
enough to to get by I still I like I
need to ask them if they like kind of a
few more members would get on because
currently it's like uh a thousand quid a
month which is not really enough to uh
Push by but I'm sure it will increase at
some point so I I'm not like a uh skint
I'm able to get by SK what a great
English word um well I irland you
bastard ah there you go I um I uh do
follow you on Instagram I just just
jumped on there it's it's
the chemo King H the king of godamn I
assure you you are not the only person
that has ever um uh mixed it up I've had
many people that have tried to like uh
like the amount of cancellation things
that we've had to try and add on to the
uh the channel for people trying to
pretend to be me which is so creepy wow
okay so the king of chemo and you'll
know it's the right one because it's
sitting at 2.6 million followers on
Instagram and the idea here is to gain
as much social media following so that
we can do more to help cancer research
um Instagram is I would assume is your
biggest
page uh nope Tik Tok is the biggest one
I think that's at 4.8 million and
YouTube I reckon some people would look
at YouTube and think like you know I
know that's probably a fake account but
for some reason YouTube isn't doing
great H so YouTube is at 20,000 and then
Tik Tok is at five million but the king
of chemo if you put that down uh those
usernames same twitch um Twitter oh wait
no what's it called now X but uh yeah
those are those are the big ones uh the
big thing that we're going to be doing
in 2024 that's really going to start
like getting a lot of uh attraction and
hopefully even making like a possibly a
documentary that makes it to Netflix is
we're going to be doing uh seven
marathons in seven different continents
on seven different days so we're going
to be going to Antarctica we're going to
going to uh Africa uh North America
South America all the way around the
world in seven days doing seven
different marathons you're do we kind of
think that's going to be like the final
thing where it's like end of
um uh end of the last one is going to be
the when we're trying to accumulate all
of the money together and that's when
we're going to really try and have the
world record smashed that's epic
and and you're talking about seven
consecutive days on seven different
continents I'm not looking forward to
doing it I mean never mind running the
marathon I don't even know if it's
feasible to get to seven different
continents on well if you're going to do
South America then Antarctica is right
is pretty close to right there right
came that's fair enough yeah we we start
in Africa we start in South Africa go
down to H
Antarctica uh oh sorry no we start in
Antarctica because uh obviously that's
the one that's going to be the most
affected by um uh weather so we actually
start like yeah travel wise travel is
actually the only opportunity that we
have where we're going to sleep we're
going to sleep on the plane and then um
yeah oh one exception uh when we are in
Istanbul uh Istanbul is a city that is
also uh Europe and uh Asia so that's the
one night of the seven where H we're
going to be able to stay in a hotel so
i' imagine that's going to be like
holy holy s cool man all right
well let's uh let's let's Scott ask um
the I think I just wanted to know like
uh you know your backstory like what
kind of what kind of brain cancer was it
or what kind of tumor so people know so
it's called a a gly blast or astroy
depending on who uh which department in
oncology you're uh speaking to and H in
terms of what caused it don't have a
clue don't have a clue then it
sounds like I mean because there's like
the the five stages of of grieving like
it seems like you're pretty much have
the acceptance but was there a point
where you went through any of those I
mean it seems like right off the bat I'm
I'm still in denial I'm not
going to pretend like I'm Zen
and it's like ah yes I've gone through
it all and I'm definitely still in the
denial phase I don't have symptoms so
it's difficult to try and get my head
around quite literally but uh I think
it's I've seen the opportunity that I
was granted and I'm just
grabbing that thing by the balls and I'm
just sort of keep busy doing that and
involves a lot of Being Fit so yeah are
you researching cures or anything like
that or you like I you know are you
looking up at late at night like is this
research going to help ultimately find a
cure for this you
think um the way I've always thought
about it is uh the longer that I can
stay alive the longer the opportunity is
that someone is going to be some clever
bastard is going to find out a way to
actually help out with the uh uh a
legitimate cure now uh at the moment I
there's loads of different sort of
anecdotal uh medicines that are around
or sort of uh ways to live your life and
I try to adhere to uh quite a lot of
that because uh my sort of rule is if it
doesn't have side effects or side
effects that are like a positive thing
then I'll take the drug or I'll do the
thing so ice baths uh lots of exercises
um long-term fasting uh uh to
um just ingesting turmeric sour so
there's loads of stuff like that
and unless it has a side effect where um
like turkey tail mushroom is one and
there's a side effect to it that some
people get like bad um Bell disorders
like just you know feeling
cramps and farts and that sort of thing
so that one is more kind of like uh I I
won't try that one but everything else
I'll do it yeah I mean it's crazy
because I'm I just turned 40 and I think
at that turning 40 phase it's like wow
I'm 40 so you have like this
existential like Crisis not really but
like you're thinking about life what's
the meaning of it you know like I'm D am
I going to die soon what's what what's
my life have meaning you haven't thought
about anything like that in that regard
yeah I've definitely done that because
that's one of the reasons why I've sort
of have this uh this huge drive like
I've often told people that H it sounds
like um an absolute mental thing
to say but cancer gave me h a huge
amount of clarity that I had never had
and a focus that I've never had before
in my life where uh it was just like
this is my goal this is what I want to
achieve I don't really want to achieve
anything else um whereas like moving up
uh through my 20s and through my 30s I
was working in a in a gym I was doing um
I like working with kids like teaching
them basic sport movements and um it was
fun I liked my job I still I still kind
of do it in its own way uh but I did
start getting this like itch in the back
of my mind where it's like where is this
going are you gonna be doing this your
whole life this is like you're you're
sort of you're going to run out of steam
with this fairly soon and then uh the
brain cancer came along and I just kind
of had the idea the thought of it and as
soon as I thought of it it was just like
do that don't focus on anything
else that is the number one goal go for
it and it kind of reminded me a lot of
um do you ever see that uh the
documentary about Dr J Dr Dre and it's
um the defiant ones yeah yeah Dr Dre is
getting interviewed and one of the
things he says in it is like oh yeah as
soon as I was a baby like my first
memories were music and there was
nothing else in my life it was just
music I was just uh had the had the uh
uh the blinkers on and it just he he
kind of felt sorry for people that
didn't have that same sort of uh Um
passion for something whatever it may be
and I remember watching that for the
first time and thinking he's right
I don't know what I want to do in my
life I feel like I'm twiddling my feet
in the paddle poool here and then on
came cancer and now now I'm Dr Dre
basically all right last
question I I was talking to this guy who
was a drug dealer and uh he got
diagnosed with something he thought he
was GNA die and he was the the question
was you know
I I guess let me just ask you this how
much are you getting for like
sympathy puss zero zero yeah no I that
is Hollywood so uh I used to be
like you know doing all right uh and
then when I had cancer it was like sort
of once I came off radiotherapy and I
started looking normal I was like all
right uh I'm making a like da and
profile here or whatever am I going to
announce I have cancer or am I going to
not announce it and then like kind of
cuz I like you know I'm I'm in my 30s
now I've I've you know around
enough that I don't really give a
about like you know just having a one
night stand I like a relationship and so
I was like you're going to need to
tell them at some point I'm
pretty sure they're GNA find out and uh
so it was like do I tell them now do I
not and it was like all right I'm not
going to tell them and you know lots of
matches or whatever and then okay I'm
going to tell them because match
dates um meeting and then the
conversation would come on to cancer at
like you know date two date three
whatever and then it's like hey I just
don't feel the spark is there anymore or
something like that and it was like ah
yeah yeah yeah and then like you know
they didn't want to say here look you're
going to die I'm not getting
love emotionally H invested in you
because like I'm going to cut you off
now because what am I going to do marry
you and in six years time you
you die I'm not I'm not getting involved
in that which is sensible I mean I mean
like it's it's horrific but at the same
time it's like that's life time to
become a
yeah again I mean my dog's
literally named kinky so I think that s
says enough about uh who I am and what
I'm about yeah you just got to get over
that
stupid oh man all right brother well
dude we're uh we're we're we're
stoked to support the cause
um candidly uh you
know I'm strok that it was such a light
lift to uh you know give somebody their
their uh fulfill their
request um and uh you genuinely were by
far the most compelling the the funniest
the the most how many entries did you
have not that many wow not not that many
and um uh they're really uh you know
there there was like a the distant
second was um a guy who said man dude I
just got sober and I'm just like um
before I got sober I went to a UFC event
and like I just blew it I acted like a
schmuck and like whatever I caused all
these problems and I want to like get it
right and you know and I was kind of
sympathetic because I'm supportive of
sobriety and you love the UFC and I love
the UFC but uh but that wasn't as
meaning I thought you were talking about
yourself for a second there when
you I genuinely did was like no but see
how you'd like sort of emulate with him
right right yeah I um but this was just
so much more meaningful for sure okay so
everybody get on the king of chemo Tik
Tok Instagram Facebook X YouTube The
Works only F also if any people saw like
as I was saying that's the most
important thing is to get the numbers
which leads to the uh subscribers and
then I give all of the subscriber money
straight in so if you are poor uh you
can still absolutely support the channel
uh but if you're the kind of person
who's like I don't have time to
flick through all that thing I just want
to give someone some money uh if you go
on to the American Cancer Society uh
their own website we're going to be
setting up the world record uh sort of
money goal and even if you're not able
to uh pay on to that yourself if you go
on you can kind of just see like there's
going to be a thermometer showing like
how close we are to Breaking the um uh
the world record so there's there's
options if you want to uh donate
yourself
or whatever you want it's open love it
man love it dude I'm a fan you're uh
you're fun to talk to like you got a
great cause you make great videos great
production value and the stuff you do so
really like everybody check out the Tik
Tok the Instagram like uh you're making
great
content yeah well that's that's the goal
thanks for helping out man yeah let's
let's all join together me on jackass
next time yeah we're we're gonna kick
cancer Square in the nuts that's right
cancer cancer yeah get someone
well actually like this obviously this
is not related but do you ever see that
episode of um s Park where uh they're
kind of taking the piss out of Kurt
Russell and he's like um ah it's it's a
really old one so you will know it's
like Kurt Russell has oh sorry not Kurt
Russell Russell Crow and it's like oh
Russell Crow I'm going around the world
fighting people and having fun or
something it's like uh right I'm gonna
uh we're goingon to beat up cancer but
we couldn't find cancer so we got to
beat up a cancer patient and it's like
Russell grow who's huge and like
beats up this cancer patient who was
like you know gone and the rest of it he
like like this and so I was saying like
like If Ever I get the opportunity to
like come in front of uh Russell kwby
like hey look man would you punch would
you take like do what you did not you
but like would you do what Kurt Russell
did in um or Russell Crow Jesus
Christ how many times I'm G I get that
wrong would you punch me in the stomach
to to try and fight
cancer that would be a pretty funny bit
for Jackass be like we're we fight we're
we're going to beat up again yeah I
think Russell Crow would tell you to
off though you'd have a better shot
with jackass my man yeah yeah there you
go but I think uh we we'd probably belly
yeah we'd have trouble doing that too
but uh but in any case man um great to
meet you and uh you know congrats on
everything that you're doing and and uh
it's evident that that your passion and
your purpose is uh is is very very
evident and um you know it's great man
so um yeah everybody follow the chemo
the king of chemo and uh that's it much
love to you Ian thank you brother thanks
again yeah thanks very much guys for
having me on and uh thanks to everybody
who's uh who's watched this and
especially those if you're watching on a
phone the person who's gone like let me
just have a little check and see the
thing thank you to those people a lot so
guys yeah you made big big difference um
hopefully we'll be able to celebrate
together at the end oh yeah man right on
brother sick cool
yeah yeah dudes all right um I'm back in
La I'm just gonna talk to my street team
here for a sec um the guy holding the
camera here want to be careful not to
show things I shouldn't
show that's Vinnie's getting married
this weekend Vinnie will not be on the
next episode of The Wild Ride podcast
because hopefully he will have his face
buried where it needs to be buried for
as long as it needs to be buried there
for his girl to arrive at her
destination where she
collect right our Lux now we call it
collecting you know um now what do I
want to talk about here um I
uh I I was I'm scared of Reddit okay cuz
people are mean scared a Reddit but I
but I don't like what am I worried about
you know I want to actually tell the the
street
team uh if you didn't already know I
shut down the steo raw membership thing
I just didn't have the heart to be
charging people when I wasn't even
posting that much there so I shut
it down and just moved it over it's now
uh a Reddit subgroup um
rsto Raw it's steo Raod the Reddit group
and um I uh I I put a little post there
with at the bottom if you've got a link
to my gnarly comedy special 100% for
free if you haven't seen it please check
that out um I'm proud of it and if you
see gnarly you think wow this was five
years ago damn and The Bucket List was
last year bug list must be way sicker
maybe I'll check out the bugy list it's
ato.com
yeah that's all I got for you today um
that was an aggressive episode let's all
wish Vinnie uh
good luck you took it like a champ today
Vinnie I did yeah I was happy with it
yeah you I mean dude we we put it all
out there we didn't hold any punches we
were
aggressive all right everybody I love
you good
deal